[Music]  with no end in sight to this wave of  crime  everyone knows you fancy lucious's  forever don't come by later yeah sure  Lucy  [Music]  you were very lucky  firing fragments here and here mr.  temporal-lobe will demonstrate a fence  if anything unusual happens I want you  to let me know straightaway  [Music]  never been the victim shut up  Morland mad at you for not being here  they were there you're talking about at  Lucy's  I heard there was some sort of vigilante  or something he's trying to take on  baganz  got ya  you don't call the devil then gob sent  when he turns up where oh where it's  Lucy I'm gonna burn the world down come  on get away with it  a special kit a special kid study lab is  over  gotta go talk to mom I'm not going  anywhere